polina are you funny I know I'm late I'm
getting in the car now I'll be there in
five
[Music]
we haven't officially met I'm Katherine
that's actress nina dobrev as
doppelgangers elena and catherine in
CW's hit supernatural drama The Vampire
Diaries remember that her first major
acting role was starring in the teenage
drama Degrassi that's with Drake the
next generation like me some Drake she's
returned to television to star on the
new CBS sitcom fam it's called Dobrev
plays Clem his life with her fiance Nick
is turned upside down when her troubled
16 year old half-sister Shannon she's
kind of a mess moves in with them in his
clip from tonight's new episode Clem
gets an unexpected request from her dad
oh hey dad what are you doing here I
came by to let you know that I'm gonna
need a plus-one to the wedding okay well
first of all you were almost a -1 so you
can bring a know what come on weddings
are romantic I want to share it with
someone special once I settle on who
that person is okay what does that even
mean it means I'm seriously dating
someone and I'm dating someone else
seriously
no wonder Shannon goes for awful guys
look at who her male role model is joins
us at the table
good to see you Nina I like when we ran
the clip from Vampire Diaries you go
wrong on the show you've had a very big
acting card sense after we played all
this because after Vampire Diaries you
were quoted as saying you know I don't
know when I'll come back to TV or and
this is a very different role and it's
comedy did it give you pause at first I
know it's called acting yeah I mean to
be honest with you you're right I wasn't
planning on coming back to television so
soon but when I got the opportunity and
got the offer for this show it was a
comedy and comedy something that I've
always loved doing but I had never
really had the chance to do or Medina me
like in Hollywood when you do one thing
well people kind of think that's do
that's all you do
yeah so I jumped at the opportunity and
I'm so happy that I did it's really fun
resident Clem is my character is pretty
flawed and she is a reformed hot mess of
her own yeah so I could relate and I
just like playing flawed characters and
being silly and the live audience aspect
was kind of scary which is that come her
terrifying I've heard but I've had I've
heard actors say both things it was
terrifying which is why I wanted to do
it I like challenges and another funny
thing is that as soon as I did do it it
was it was as scary as I thought it
would be so much so that my heart felt
like it was gonna jump out of my body
and I and I really honestly didn't want
the pilot to get picked up I was like I
don't think I can live under the stress
for 22 episodes if the joke is working
or not working that's good yeah yeah
although feeling when you say something
no but let's supposed to be funny really
good and the writers are really
challenging the creators though like we
we didn't really have that many misses
so it ended up going well ultimately but
I didn't think that I could do that for
so long and then and then I got used to
it after a couple episodes of now I feel
super comfortable and I love it and and
I'm so happy that it did get picked up
but I'm speaking real-time don't they
change lines while you're doing it today
you're changing lines new lines in front
of a lot yeah you're trusting jokes kind
of a live audience and what's the most
surprising thing about being in front of
a live audience thus far having to pause
for laughter yeah I mean you some people
you have to either have rhythm or you
don't and that part of it I've figured
out that luckily I do because you can
track to it no you have to kind of like
stand there and that's what I couldn't
figure out was like gee when they laugh
and you have to pot like do you just
freeze like a tableau acting then does
that carry over in real life like I say
things that are funny people don't laugh
at all you have to not react in help
laughs this is a thing that Nora you'll
like this about her she loves working
out something what's wrong with you
because Nora's new year's resolution was
to work out every single day but you
said you loved working out that's good
for you well even if it's just for ten
minutes I mean I can't say it's for
extended periods of time I every damn
day thing you know I work out every day
too and sometimes if I'm too tired to go
to the gym I consider alcoholic beverage
a liver without exercising a muscle it's
a different muscle so were creative work
out there like like you just made
yourself more popular at this table Nina
just sold her first script for a movie
that she can't discuss but we want to
say congratulations all right here on
CBS we'll be right back